these has-beens are done playing
fahrenheit 451. yeah before any podcast
is dispersed run it by these jackasses
first their songs may be old and tired
but they still want joe rogan fired so
it's us or joe say the leftovers from am
radio
blasting joe rogan for misinformation
although they're old enough to die from
constipation
that's a lot of rhyming i could make up
my mind so harry meg what i call prince
harry and his wife
apparently expressed concerns about
covet misinfo on spotify where they also
have a podcasting deal so far that 25
million dollar podcast deal resulted in
just a single 30-minute episode if i
were spotify i'd express concerns about
that
you know you'd think they came from
royalty
a spokesperson says the couple have
continued to express concerns to spotify
to ensure changes to its platform blah
blah blah and address help public health
crisis meanwhile their washed up
artisans have joined neil young asking
spotify to pull their music and
objection to rogan including bruce
springsteen's guitarist nils lofgren
a poor man cc deville
[Laughter]
thank you
neal is also the number of his songs
anyone remembers
and there's the homeless cat lady joni
mitchell for a quick refresh let's hear
her biggest hit
don't it always seem to go
don't know what you got to do
paradise put up a pocket
[Music]
magical i tell you
anyway spotify has since announced
they'll add a content advisory to any
podcast that discusses coven
which rogan happily welcomed they never
make me stop he also said this
i want to thank spotify for being so
supportive during this time
and i'm very sorry that this is
happening to them and that they're
taking so much heat from it i'm not
trying to promote misinformation i've
never tried to do anything with this
podcast other than just talk to people i
do all the scheduling myself and i don't
always get it right i am going to do my
best
in the future to balance things out but
my point of doing this is always just to
create interesting conversations
and ones that i hope people enjoy i just
notice what a perfectly oval-shaped head
he has
but that wasn't even as half as
interesting as what rogan discussed late
last week
namely the second best-looking person on
tonight's panel i was walking through
new york times square with douglas
murray about a month ago and we were we
had gone to an opera there's these
people dressed up like superheroes
spider-man ran up to me and he said are
you jordan peterson and i said are you
spider-man and that was pretty damn
funny and then douglas murray we were
walking by and he dug this where he said
i wish he would have asked me if i was
douglas
[Laughter]
he's murray this sparkling sense of
humor that goes along with his insane
courage he's very careful
murray that guy's got a spine of steel
he certainly does and he backs it up
with consideration and thought he shuts
people down in a
pretty beautiful way
and now i'm here yes
yeah
good directing there guys
[Laughter]
thank you for that yes my pleasure
you've got quite a fan club there what
do you make of royalty
well on principal of course i never say
anything bad about any members of their
office
but fortunately they've left the royal
family yeah i can just uh say what i
like
look i mean um
nobody would say that prince harry is
the smartest member of the family
um and uh well he's definitely not the
dumbest with uh meg
uh well
i certainly wouldn't give either of them
permission to decide what anyone can
listen to um
they have as you said managed to hoover
up what 25 million from spotify uh and
they've issued a great typical uh uh
sort of very untouched sussex thing if
you ever doubt about anything you should
always think what would the duke and
duchess exactly get it tattooed on your
knuckles if you forget
and uh yeah there's always they say that
they're worried about misinformation
this is this is a great way in our era
that you uh you just shut up anything
yeah that is what we used to call asking
questions
oh it's misinformation well
you know
what joe rogan does on his podcast
is ask questions of people and he
listens to the answers and now most of
the mainstream media haven't done that
in a long time and he gives people
long-form opportunities to talk and he
has scientists on like three hours right
and uh you know so far joe rogan has
done far more for public information
then the sussexes are likely to do even
if they live an awfully long time you
are very very right and you bring up the
point of the length cat it's like three
hours i am a joe rogan fan i can't even
watch one podcast because i can't i
don't have the time he does like five of
them a week 15 hours of content
i don't believe any of these people
have and i'm saying that as a fan i
don't i watch maybe one i don't believe
any of these people have even watched or
could find joe rogan on the podcast no i
don't think they have googled him either
probably because yeah he's had some
vaccine skeptics on he also had cnn's
chief medical correspondent on in 2020
he also basically endorsed bernie
sanders he's not exactly mr maga right
yeah they're not canceling him for that
they're trying to cancel him because he
has had conversations
with people they disagree with which is
a remarkably low bar there's nobody that
would not be cancelled under that mm-hmm
no does that make sense no sandra why
aren't
spotify has real issues with the royalty
situation they always have and it's like
wouldn't you want to help your fellow
musicians out there i mean obviously
joni mitchell's wealthy uh uh the other
guy neil young's wealthy wouldn't he
they want to help the
rather than screwing everybody over it
wouldn't make it more sense well you say
fellow musicians you just mean fellow
famous people and i wonder i wonder how
long they speak out you saw what
happened to spotify's went way down in
value on this story major had i believe
it's coming back because wall street's
saying buy this this is going to go away
really fast how long are those ex-royals
really going to speak out against
their big money-maker for that for their
household at this point a lot to say
about them by the way that country
embraced them when that was there for
the wedding and i still don't know what
it was other than kate middleton and
jealousy i don't know but harry is a
sweetheart and i wish i wish that family
could
and they loved megan and they embraced
her and i wish they would have stayed
together but wait hold on so so spotify
um everybody cares about the bottom line
i think if you heard joe rogan's apology
there i mean that sounded very sincere
to me i hate what this has done to
spotify because he's worried about what
he's going to do that was a really good
apology and by the way joni mitchell
neil young we were talking about this in
the green room go back and look at the
uh an addition they did of helpless
singing together i don't know you might
not think that they were of a sound mind
like they're putting themselves as the
moral authority the fact checkers of the
universe and trying to shut down joe
rogan from asking questions i think
there's a lot of people repeating what
joe rogan does on that podcast without
taking as we have all in our homework if
you didn't listen regularly taking the
time to do he is trying to get
information and he hears from a big
range of voices and that is fact by the
way can i i haven't heard a whole bunch
of joni mitchell but did you dub that
that's actually one of her earlier
bigger hits back when uh you know uh
that was in it was uh i believe they
called it screech rock i actually like i
feel really bad for joni mitchell fans
like these women weren't depressed
enough without getting roped into a
coveted debate yes it's like they were
sitting at home deciding whether or not
to adopt another cat and now they're on
the front lines of a freaking war about
coven yes and shame on these people
because they clearly don't listen to his
podcast right and we've all kind of
circled in but what he does is he's
smoking about a yard of weed an episode
except having very deep long
conversations they portray anyone who
doesn't agree with him is some kind of a
mag a strong man but he's the antithesis
of that right and that's the part that
is so frustrating but these musicians
see this as a branding exercise they
want to come out and look virtuous like
they're on the right side of this but if
we cared about misinformation there's a
label over every fouchy video you'd ever
watch for the rest of your life yeah
yeah it's also you know misinformation
is the new hate speech i think it goes
to the sports world as well greg and how
we all just kind of as fans hungry for
entertainment and you know good viewing
of sports and good listening of good
music and the podcast for gosh sake we
just kind of wish musicians would stay
in there it'd be nice and i'd love to
see you guys
and harry and meghan are just lazy to
that point they've given him one episode
in two years they're just trying to get
out of their way it's disgusting and i i
can't stand them just shut up they're
not even real royals they're like kansas
city
oh how dare you don't even step out not
bring george brett into this
conversation the only way he wears the
crown is if he has a birthday at burger
king like get over yourself shut up they
let anyone wear those crowns that is
true hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else